aucun événement n'est pas parti les
mains vides après avoir perdu son poste
de pdg chez bombardier au contraire vous
allez voir les chiffres l'arrangement
conclu avec l'entreprise prévoit qu'il
va toucher une prime de départ de 6
millions neuf cent soixante quinze mille
dollars américains
à cela il faut ajouter près de 3
millions 500 mille dollars qui lui
seront versés
lorsque la conclusion de la vente de
bombardier transport et alstom sera fait
les attributions les options d'actions
qu'il avait acquise val près de deux
millions de dollars au total
il s'ouvre il recevra plus de 12
millions de dollars
mentionnons qu alain bellemare a touché
une rémunération de 7 millions 621 1300
$ pour son travail l'an dernier avant
qu'il ne soit remercié en mars
lombardi aujourd'hui est toujours dans
une situation financière précaire avec
une dette de plus de 9 milliards de
dollars
l'action ne vaut plus que 41 cents on se
tourne donc vers michel nadeau expert en
finances et en gouvernance et monsieur
nadeau c'est l'équivalent 17 millions de
dollars canadiens qui pourraient être
versés alain bellemare qu'est ce que
vous pensez de ce montant c'est une
somme énorme évidemment ces ententes
sont souvent signées lorsqu'il ya des
beaux jours entre la compagnie et le
nouveau président en 2015
allez bellemare est arrivé c'était un
ancien de du monde 0 nautique américaine
québécois qui avait réussi donc on lui a
tracé olio jeter un pont d'or sous ses
pieds pour qu'il vienne travailler chez
bombardier
c'est à dire une prime de deux ans plus
les bois dit salaires les bonis advenant
qu'il est seraient congédiés sans cause
or donc c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui il
reçoit 7 millions est-ce qu'on n'aurait
pas dû mettre quelques conditions pour
que ce 7 millions l'eau soit versée ben
là je ne sois pense que c'est se promène
une leçon à retenir pour la prochaine
fois mais voilà parce que qu'est-ce
qu'on rémunère avec ces montants là
habituellement on récompense le succès
mais là quel succès donc c'est
effectivement ce que monsieur bellemare
avait promis c'est une réorganisation
ses preuves démantèlement de bombardier
et à ce sujet là évidemment on le dit on
leur donnait 3 millions nle à monsieur
bellemare à février et on ne dira mot
donné 3 millions
baba sy avec les autres cad si vous êtes
présent dans 18 mois pour la signature
de l'entente avec alstom stockage une
entente de huit milliards et demi
donc c'est important que tous les cadres
restent avec bombardier pour bien
négocier avec alison la pente
la division transport oui l'euro ce qui
paraissait se demande monsieur nadeau
pourquoi est-ce qu'on devrait payer
davantage des pdg si la transaction avec
la somme de concrétiser ce que ça fait
pas partie des tâches d'un pdg de tenir
des négociations pour une transaction
aussi il avait raison mais lors on
voulait le gardait tout prix mais ce qui
t'arrive est ce qu on lui fit signe
c'est tintin cela on lui dit en février
voilà on va te donner trois milliards et
demi de dollars américains plaignants
mais la 2 2 millions de dollars
américains si tu es là au milieu de l'an
prochain quand on voit un signe et
parfinir conclure l'entente avec un stop
mais trois semaines plus tard il
congédie religion sigle au fessier
linthal et textiles ou pour un que
préparer un plan de congédiement de
monsieur bel bat à moi je trouve que
trois millions et demi
monsieur bellemare ne participera pas
les négociations avec alstom
il sera pas là au moment de la signature
avec alstom donc encore une fois
pourquoi avoir en fera faire ce montant
de trois millions et demi la diva est à
donner aux cadres qui sont présents qui
vont rester braqué six mois encore pour
négocier avec alstom pour y négocier que
les autorités européennes de la
concurrence etc ratchet et rock
donc monsieur bellemare sera pas là or
donc créé les ti lui donner ce 3
millions et demi sachant qu'on allait
congédier
la question est lancée on comprend excès
c'est choquant de voir qu'on verse des
millions à un ex pdg même si c'est prévu
au contrat là parce qu'on va se rappeler
d'un événement comme celui qui a
démantelé le fleuron québécois alors que
le prix de l'entreprise est toujours
endettés toujours en référé le dise aux
publications lorsqu'on signe de contrôle
l'entente
évidemment ce type monsieur bellemare
cette sauvage y arrive là comme un
sauveur de tout le monde ce massif
on a peur qu'il y ait que quand le pet
quelques musées châble et là on lui
donne tout ce qu'ils demandent
habituellement c'est comme ça que ça se
passe
on lui donne à peu près tout ce qu'il
demande parce qu'on veut tellement qu'il
vienne travailler pour nous mais on ne
prévoit pas que s'il déçoit
s'il ne rencontre pas les objectifs
photo peut-être le congédier sans cause
triplement rien volé yeux rien fait de
mal mais y'a pas livré la marchandise et
qu'à ce moment là s'il arrive sur bella
évidemment ça mérite plus un salaire
plus les bonis monsieur bellemare a été
très bien payé durant les cinq ans qui a
passé chez bombardier
s il mérite et en plus vraiment de 7
millions pour cette période de départ et
ce en cause
je ne suis pas certain ouais bon la
question aussi ce qui est sensible c'est
qu'il ya des fonds publics dans cette
entreprise là on n'a pas fermé la porte
d'ailleurs investir encore dans
bombardier là pour aider l'entreprise à
travers cette crise ont l'impression de
grâce je pense qu'il faudrait investir
d'un bombardier parce que bombardier
aura besoin comme toutes les compagnies
aériennes
toutes les fabricants d'avions re besoin
de l'aide vers le mental parce que les
acheteurs du dobro 7 mai saissac
tuellement ne sont pas en mesure pour
des questions évidentes de venir
chercher leurs appareils donc bombardier
robot jouet de bridge de 500 millions
cinq cent millions au cours des 12
prochains bourse est très clair un
braire boeing va recevoir 7 milliards
d'êtres humains américain airbus à peu
près la même chose
ouais rémunération des rythmes
énergiques martel monsieur nadeau en
terminant 5 millions pour diriger ce qui
reste de bombarder ça vous semble juste
oui je sais que c'est conforme se
conforment chopin c'est un montage quoi
ces 5 millions $ us soit à part ça ça
veut dire 7 millions donc c'est une
bonne augmentation pour monsieur martel
qui revient à ses anciennes amours
bombardier aéronautique de juste le
petit point moi c'est boni de signature
de six cent mille dollars
moi je pense cette notion de boni de
signature aux dons et à des joueurs
qu'il met d'un code à draka des employés
des gens qui arrivent chez hydro-québec
allée jacques du nouveau employé chez
bombardier
leur donne un boni d'accueil quand leur
chanter une petite chanson this is a lie
quand l'europe chocolat defla mais de la
600 milles de large et peut-être pas
nécessaire
michel nadeau merci beaucoup pour vos
commentaires enfin